j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
vous le savez volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour je vous propose de
revenir sur la décision de l'actrice
Adel et nel d'arrêter le cinéma et de
politiser son geste elle dénonce je la
cite la complaisance généralisée du
métier pour les agresseurs sexuels 5 ans
et demi après le début du mouvement me
too où en est le 7e art notamment en
France avant d'en débattre retour sur
l'ouverture du Festival de Cannes ou la
présence de Johnny Depp sur le tapis
rouge fait polémique Renaud parquet
derrière les vivas du Festival de Cannes
se cachent la polémique et les critiques
en ligne de mire sur le tapis rouge
Johnny Depp présent à la cérémonie pour
présenter le film Jeanne du Barry de
Maïwenn l'acteur américain est banni des
plateaux de tournage de Hollywood après
son procès qu'il opposait à son
ex-compagne empereur pour violence
conjugale si une partie de ces
accusations violences ont été récusées
en justice il a repris le chemin des
plateaux de tournage là où son
ex-compagne a subi des cyber-harcèlement
virulents il tente de répondre aux
critiques
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne ma personne et ma vie
la majorité de ce que vous avez lu est
une fiction imaginaire horrible le fait
est que comme je le disais nous sommes
ici pour parler d'un film mais vous
savez c'est comme quand on pose la
question comment ça va mais qu'en
réalité le sous-texte est mon Dieu je te
déteste
la présence annoncée de celui qui
incarne Louis XV dans le nouveau film de
la réalisatrice de police ADN ou
pardonnez-moi passe mal auprès des
collectifs d'acteurs fervent défenseur
de l'égalité des sexes et contre la
violence dans le cinéma au point qu'une
tribune parue dans Libération est signée
par une centaine de personnalités parmi
lesquelles Julie Gayet ou alors qu'elle
a mis égratignent l'institution et ce
juste avant l'ouverture du Festival de
Cannes en déroulant le tapis rouge aux
hommes et aux femmes qui agressent le
festival des montres que les violences
dans les milieux de création peuvent
s'exercer en toute impunité nous
subissons bien trop souvent des
agressions sexuelles du harcèlement
moral et du racisme au sein même de nos
lieux de travail lorsque nous avons le
courage de parler ou demander de l'aide
nous nous entendons trop souvent dire
tais-toi s'il te plaît pour la vie du
film il arrive même que des producteurs
et productrices soient prêts ou prêtes à
acheter notre silence acheter le silence
c'est ce qui avait mis le feu aux
poudres il y a 5 ans lors de l'affaire
Weinstein est lancé le mouvement me too
qui déverrouillait la parole des femmes
victimes de harcèlement sexuel à
l'époque le très influent producteur
hollywoodien était accusé par des
dizaines d'actrices de les avoir abusé
sexuellement et d'acheter leur mutisme
contre de l'argent le mouvement devient
planétaire mais en France la vague a du
mal à s'implanter c'est d'autant plus
difficile en France
du fait du culte de l'auteur l'idéologie
selon laquelle les artistes sont
au-dessus des lois de par leur de peur
talents ou leur des génies que le talent
et le génie
justifie toutes les
disons toutes les transgressions et je
ce terme on a à la fois des
éléments qu'on peut
identifier comme politique et puis des
éléments qui sont simplement des abus de
pouvoir les paroles se libèrent les
accusations pleuvent de par Dieu Besson
Polanski à son sujet Adèle Hennel primé
au César en 2020 fut une sortie
remarquée ne supportant pas qu'il soit
récompensés pour son film j'accuse trois
ans au passé et l'actrice va encore plus
loin dans une interview elle entend
dénoncer la complaisance généralisée du
métier vis-à-vis des agresseurs sexuels
et la manière dont ce milieu collabore
avec l'ordre mortifère écosside raciste
du monde l'actrice a décidé de se mettre
en retrait du cinéma
on débat tout de suite autour de ce
thème de ces thèmes Hélène féclinger
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes maîtresse de
conférence à l'Université Paris 8 et
historienne du cinéma Michel Guérin
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef au monde et vous
écrivez évidemment cette chronique
hebdomadaire sur la culture Clémentine
Charlemagne bonsoir bienvenue à vous
délégué général de l'association cinéma
pour tous qu'aux présidente du Collectif
55 50 en duplex avec nous les Nike
Bridoux qui est journalistes Mediapart
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes responsable
éditorial aux questions de genre et vous
avez publié une longue enquête
concernant Gérard Depardieu on y
reviendra évidemment Émilie s'appelle
ski et éditoris pour sciences public est
resté à mes côtés je vais je vais
commencer on va presque prendre le même
déroulé que dans le le sujet de Renault
parquet à l'instant et je vais démarrer
par la première polémique qui ouvrait ce
festival de Cannes fallait-il l'ouvrir
avec ce film de Maïwenn qui offre le
rôle de Louis XV à Johnny Depp je le
rappelle
acteur aujourd'hui blacklisté aux
États-Unis c'était quoi une erreur une
maladresse une faute vous dites quoi par
rapport à ça plus qu'une maladresse
assurément en tout cas c'est à
contre-courant de ce qui se passe depuis
un certain nombre d'années évidemment
dans la lignée de demi-tour mais aussi à
contre-courant de ce qui se passe au
niveau de la transformation profonde de
la société probablement en même temps
voilà le
l'issue du festival c'est effectivement
la récompense adressée par Jane Fonda
icône par ailleurs du féminisme au
cinéma s'il en est à une troisième
réalisatrice et deuxième française en
l'occurrence Justine Triet donc une
lecture totalement simpliste ou binaire
de ce de ce festival c'est ce que vous
nous dites absolument pas et il faut
aussi regarder l'ensemble de la
programmation quand même du festival il
y a énormément de films de femmes par
ailleurs qui ont été programmées dans la
section officielle mais aussi et dans
des sections parallèles et notamment de
jeunes générations à regarder de près
alors dans la foulée de de la
déclaration d'année lennel on l'a vu
dans le sujet de Renault parquet qui qui
annonce voilà mettre fin sa carrière et
vouloir politiser ce cette décision il y
a une tribune signée par plus de 523
actrices et acteurs publiées dans
Libération ils disent ceci en déroulant
le tapis rouge aux hommes et aux femmes
qui agressent le festival envoie le
message que dans notre pays nous ne
pouvons continuer d'exercer des
violences en toute impunité nous pouvons
évidemment que la violence est
acceptable dans les lieux de création
Michel Guérin est-ce que vous vous
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
formulation
la canne qui déroule le tapis rouge aux
hommes et aux femmes qui agressent
est-ce que ça vous semble exagéré
justifier que chacun voilà ce n'est pas
d'avis vraiment là-dessus au sens où non
la question c'est la formulation c'est
moi ce qui je suis toujours embêté quand
en généralise c'est à dire quand au
violeur c'est matériel je crois donc
c'était pas simplement visé je sais pas
je pense qui était visé surtout cette
année là je pense Johnny Depp non je je
pensais c'était cette personne donc
c'est la généralisation alors ensuite la
question c'est tout l'ensemble de la de
ce texte qui donne des témoignages mais
des témoignages sont non sans qui est de
nom de personnalité donnée et donc il
donne l'impression que de manière
sociologique j'ai envie de manière
approfondeur dans les tournages il y a
beaucoup de problèmes presque systémique
systémique adalenet d'ailleurs le disait
également a déjà c'est quand même assez
fascinant Adèle et nel il y a eu cette
entretien avec Télérama mais un an
auparavant elle donne deux entretiens à
deux joueurs aux différents étrangers
elle dit exactement la même chose et
personne ne bouge ça passe rien c'est
fascinant quand même et avec une
violence inouïe pareil alors aussi moi
c'est ce que je regrette un peu dans la
déclaration d'adnl c'est une façon de
généraliser
et en fait de dire gros comme si tout le
monde comme si c'était intrinsèque à ce
milieu du cinéma que en fait ce cinéma
est violent c'est pour ça que le thème
je crois 4 violeur était venu presque un
slogan en début de festival après je
pense en fait comme vous l'avez dit il y
a c'est là on voit quand même dans tous
les sections les films les films montrer
ses soucis une caisse de résonance
incroyable et donc ça permet aussi à des
cinéastes et des signes à cette femme de
de montrer de montrer beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs les oeuvres qu'elles font et
donc voilà donc il y a tout cette
ambiguïté donc peut-être une un petit
peu d'injustice dans le procès fait à
Thierry Frémont en tout cas
simplification moi je vais retenir ça
des deux premières interventions
Clémentine Charlemagne sur je vous avais
mené sur cette idée de finalement d'un
système qui resterait alors qu'on est 5
ans 5 ans et demi après MiTo qui
resterait finalement protecteur ou
favorables à ceux qui agressent pour
reprendre la formulation de la tribune
ou effectivement ceux qui pratiquent des
des violences
en direction des femmes est-ce que vous
dites ça aussi en fait ce qui
m'interpelle c'est que je vois pas
vraiment une généralisation je vois
plutôt la dénonciation d'une culture et
c'est pas vraiment qu'elle que la
tribune dénonce quelque chose en général
mais il y a une réelle culture de la
violence des rapports dans le cinéma
encore aujourd'hui pour vous et encore
aujourd'hui c'est c'est enfin je j'ai
même pas je peux enfin il y a pas de
chiffres qui existent là dessus mais en
fait avec le collectif 55 ans on
organise régulièrement des ateliers on
est également régulièrement contacté par
par des personnes par des structures
voilà le les violences sont là elles
lors de la conférence de presse du film
de Justin triey qui a justement été
récompensé la comédienne
a vu l'heure elle a mis en avant le fait
que sur le tournage elle n'avait ressent
aucune pression de la part de Justin
trier et elle disait j'aimerais que
beaucoup s'en inspirent parce qu'en fait
c'était génial j'ai adoré j'ai adoré ça
et et tout s'est très bien passé et
croyez moi je sais de quoi je parle
voilà donc je pense qu'en fait il y a
c'est
j'aime j'aimerais dire que non tout va
bien parce qu'en fait il y a de très
belles œuvres qui qui ont la chance
d'éclore voilà dans la violence sans
violence voilà je pense que tout ça
n'est pas vraiment corrélé en fait mais
le fait que non effectivement le monde
du cinéma est assez violent Emilie
intervenir qu'on a du mal à traiter ça
qu'on arrive pas à avoir de ligne de
conduite et on voit que dans le milieu
politique c'est la même chose je prends
un exemple moi je vois vraiment le
parallèle entre le l'acteur fétiche dans
les amandiers de Valeria bruneté Deski
qui était quand même accusé avant
qu'elle l'embauche pour ce film je crois
que ce compagnon aussi ça peut être la
eu du mal du coup à décider et la même
chose pour des ministres qui ont été
nommés alors qu'ils étaient accusés eux
aussi ont genre cytréand quand même
parmi les plus grands puisque ça a été
c'est le premier flic de France Gérald
Darmanin on ne sait pas comment traiter
ces sujets il faut le rater parce que
après après il y a la question de ce que
la justice oui donc le soupçon reste
mais ce que je veux dire j'essaye de
faire attention à ça quoi j'ai
d'ailleurs la question se pose aussi
pour pour les acteurs ou les comédiens
Abad qui avait été accusé il y a une
enquête quand même il est resté au
gouvernement ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on ne sait pas comment traiter ça
auparavant est-ce qu'on peut embaucher
un acteur qui a été accusé est-ce qu'on
interdit à une personnalité de faire son
métier sur le soupçon en fait c'est ça
la question que vous posez excusez-moi
d'avance c'est difficile moi j'ai du mal
à ne pas aimer les films de Roman
Polanski que j'ai beaucoup aimé parce
que j'ai entendu dire tout ça mais je
trouve que maintenant on devrait se
fixer une ligne de conduite qui soit
assez clair pour éviter ces propos et
vous savez ce qu'on appelle
jurisprudence va la dur je donne la
parole tout de suite un ministre mis en
examen doit démissionner
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à trouver une
ligne de conduite parce que vous avez en
fait deux façons vous avez deux cultures
qui s'affrontent j'ai envie de dire faut
prendre un peu le mot vous avez donné
c'est que vous avez ce qui pense que la
seule ligne à tenir c'est celle du droit
de la loi et de et de et de la
jurisprudence et des procès et dans
C'est un peu la joie Terry Frémaux et
c'est pour ça que Terry Frémaux
d'ailleurs programme le film de Maïwenn
avec Johnny Depp estimement que il y a
pas eu de condamnation contre lui il y a
eu un procès en diffamation il y a eu
enfin voilà mais on fera un petit peu
d'accord mais en plus
vous avez une autre ligne qui est très
bien défendue d'ailleurs parallèle qui
dit la justice on s'assoit dessus la
justice n'est pas fiable la justice est
un frein à notre combat et donc aller
concilier ces deux lignes bonne chance
alors la ligne la ligne tirée justement
on va écouter le délégué général du
Festival de Cannes donc il organise une
conférence de presse pour justifier le
choix d'ouvrir
cette édition avec le film de Maïwenn je
ne connais pas l'image de Johnny Depp
aux États-Unis pour vous dire la vérité
nous on voit un film
moi j'ai une seule conduite dans la vie
c'est la liberté de penser la liberté de
parler la liberté d'agir dans le cadre
de la loi
et donc si Johnny Depp il avait été
interdit lui avait été interdit de jouer
dans un film et si ce film là avait été
interdit
on ne serait pas en train d'en parler
alors on n'a pas encore entendu les
nights Bridoux dont je me tourne vers
vous peut-être pour alors on a regardé
évidemment c'est assez compliqué quand
on parle de cette affaire parce qu'il y
a eu des procès en diffamation entre
Johnny Depp et son ex-compagne les deux
ont été condamnés Johnny Depp a des
dommage intérêts de 2 millions de
dollars si je ne me trompe et son
ex-compagne a beaucoup plu et si on dit
formellement l'acteur Johnny Depp n'a
pas été condamné aux États-Unis pour
violence conjugales j'ai essayé d'être à
peu près précis dans les mots est-ce que
pour autant il faut l'interdire les
blacklisté comme le font les Américains
moi je suis pas là pour donner des bons
et des mauvais points et dire qui peut
embaucher qui sur tel tournage
franchement je pensais pas du tout de
l'ordre de mon compétences par contre ce
qu'on peut dire effectivement précis
être précise moi j'ai tout à fait
entendu tirer vraiment quand il a
expliqué qu'il s'intéressait pas du tout
à ce qui s'était passé aux États-Unis
mais manifestement il ne sait pas non
plus intéressé à ce qui s'est passé en
Grande-Bretagne parce qu'en fait il y a
eu deux procès différents dans le cas de
Johnny Depp qui a effectivement le
procès en diffamation pour lequel il a
été reconnu coupable aux États-Unis tout
comme son ancienne compagnon bird qui a
été davantage condamné que lui mais il a
en revanche perdu son procès en
diffamation qu'il avait intenté contre
un tableau de britannique il y a trois
ans de mémoire qu'il avait présenté
comme un mari violent et le tribunal
avait considéré que plusieurs des
épisodes étaient avérés mais tout ça ne
constitue pas une condamnation pour
violence conjugale simplement ça ça pose
quand même qu'il y a eu des décisions de
justice il y a pas rien en termes de
justice mais plus fondamentalement ça
pose la question comme dans tous les
milieux et pas uniquement dans celui du
cinéma sur la justice est-elle la seule
boussole qui doit présider au débat sur
le le sujet faut-il une condamnation
faut-il que cette condamnation soit
définitive une mise en examen est à
juger suffisante ça c'est sur le point
de judiciaire mais par ailleurs il y a
d'autres terrains qui sont fondamentaux
par exemple les employeurs ont des
obligations dans le droit du travail
d'assurer la sécurité de leur salarié
ils doivent mener des enquêtes internes
ils peuvent licencier des salariés pour
des faits qui leur sembleraient avérés
par ces enquêtes internes c'est aussi le
cas par exemple si on prend le cas du
CNC pour prendre l'exemple du cinéma le
CNC aujourd'hui a sorti son financement
du cinéma à des formations obligatoires
sur les violences excités sexuelles ça
montre bien que la justice n'est pas le
la seule le seul organe habilité à dire
le juste si je puis dire et heureusement
d'ailleurs parce que par ailleurs elle
manque cruellement moyen pour le faire
alors ce débat il est également
passionnant parce que ça nous permet de
faire un bilan du mouvement me too et
peut-être tiens pour commencer ce
souvenir de ce que les les hommes de
cinéma les hommes de pouvoir au cinéma
ont fait subir aux femmes en toute
impunité pendant des décennies je vous
propose un témoignage c'est la
journaliste et auteur Annette Lévy
Villard qui était l'invité de l'émission
je suis en train de chercher le titre de
l'émission elle est là de Rebecca
Fitoussi allons plus loin elle était
donc sur notre antenne elle publie cette
journaliste chronique du nom de choc mis
tout ce coup la planète et elle nous
parle de qui elle nous parle de Marilyn
Monroe et des années 50 marilyn était
dans ce système hollywoodien qui a été
un système de de médiévale de droit de
cuissage de tous les patrons de
Hollywood depuis le début de rendez-vous
des studios les Warner les Myers on va
tous les gens qui ont créé le cinéma
américain avait toujours
ces pratiques scandaleuses des jeunes
Américains qui venaient du milieu et qui
devait passer par le casting sur le
canapé ça s'appelle casincar pour avoir
un rôle et Marilyn Monroe comme les
autres et dans sa biographie elle
raconte que oui il est un bordel géant
les années 50
Hélène fréquence il y a eu des voix qui
se sont élevées pour dénoncer ce ce
voilà ce qui vient d'être raconté est-ce
qu'il y en a eu beaucoup et comment
elles ont été
étouffées parce que finalement on a
l'impression que tout a commencé avec
Mitou alors il y a eu pas mal de
témoignages déjà et écrit évidemment
alors à une échelle internationale
évidemment dans le contexte Lydia mais
aussi en France par exemple dans les
années
1970 au cœur du mouvement de libération
des femmes dont un net les vigilates a
été l'une des pionnières des voix se
sont élevées et on retrouve enfin moi
dans le cadre de mes recherches j'ai
retrouvé des textes extrêmement précis
dans un texte par exemple de Michka
Gorki qui c'est pas anecdotique à
codiriger le département réalisation de
la FEMIS entre 1997 et 2016 et qui a
notamment eu dans ses promotions Céline
siama et donc Michka gore qui écrivait
en 1976 un texte qui s'appelait art
dramatique ou prostitution dans lequel
elle explique exactement ce qui se passe
sur nombre de plateaux elle dit est-ce
qu'un réalisateur a le droit d'humilier
de traumatisés d'avilir des comédiens et
des comédiennes sous prétexte qu'un
public prétendu refouler aurait besoin
de compenser par voyeurisme son absence
de sexualité elle parle de réalisateur
proxénète qui soupait leur comédienne
qui plus est obligés par la force des
circonstances ou la force tout court de
satisfaire pour le même prix des hommes
excités par l'ambiance aphrodisiaque des
nécessités tournages on a énormément de
témoignages écrits dans les années 70 et
depuis évidemment mais simplement ces
voilà n'ont pas toujours été entendus
elles se sont exprimées la conscience
était plus ou moins évidemment
formalisée pas forcément selon les mêmes
termes que ceux de l'air postnito
néanmoins ces paroles étaient là
simplement elles étaient peut-être moins
nombreuses moins libérées moins écoutez
surtout et ça je pense que c'est un
point très important est-ce que ça les
pas plus loin même je me souviens de
parce qu'on donnait à propos des films
de Melville ou de Robert Bresson
ou presque on s'était comment dire
c'était un fait positif que ces
cinéastes malmenaient les acteurs comme
les actrices il faut les pousser dans
leur retranchement c'est une façon
d'inventer quelque chose de différent
c'était un acte ça participait de l'acte
créatif enfin c'était en tout cas jugé
comme cela alors soit cette fois pour de
bons soit pour justifier un comportement
pour une palme d'or il y a eu quand même
un énorme débat en Suisse sur le nombre
de prises qu'il pratiquaient sur
quelques actes sexuels simulés ou pas
j'en sais rien mais enfin et cela il se
comportait il y a eu quand même
les actrices ont plus ou moins dit des
choses enfin c'était quand il y a une
tension énorme sur ce tournage
[Musique]
bien passé qui ont été des très beaux
films j'ai eu des tournages qui se sont
mal passés qui ont été les mauvais films
tournages qui sont mal passés qui ont
été des beaux films aussi mais en fait
ça peut pas justifier ça peut pas
justifier la violence du réalisateur ou
de la réalité c'est-à-dire que on a
tendance à négliger parce que en fait à
partir du moment où
on s'engage en fait dans ces métiers du
cinéma c'est un peu la même chose que
dans le journalisme je pense c'est à
dire qu'on est passionné on fait ça
parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous
anime qu'on a vraiment envie de faire ça
nous semble important c'est voilà on
vibre à travers à travers tout ça et
puis en fait bah on se dit bah ouais bah
du coup il faut que j'en passe par des
choses un peu compliquées parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe c'est
comme ça que ça se passe puis en fait au
bout d'un moment aussi c'est marrant je
suis détruit en fait et et donc c'est
c'est tellement en fait courant
d'entendre des témoignages comme ça
c'est à dire que les 123 acteurs et
actrices qui parlent tout et tous ont
vraiment dit on en peut plus de ces
comportements là et c'est et c'est pas
n'importe quel n'importe quel personne
et il faut faut savoir que à la fois les
acteurs sont et actrices sont en
première ligne parce que c'est elle et
eux qui se retrouve à défendre les films
ensuite en promotion et donc c'est aussi
très violent parfois de devoir dire bah
ouais c'était super alors qu'en fait
c'était pas du tout super mais il y a
aussi certains réalisateurs certaines
réalisatrices qui les préservent un peu
plus parce que justement c'est il y a
des questions de pouvoir en fait qui se
jouent et qui par contre vont se
déchaîner sur des personnes de l'équipe
mais à quel à quel titre est-ce qu'on a
le droit de maltraiter des gens pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a le droit de faire ça
qu'est-ce qui justifierait de pouvoir
maltraiter des gens et de ne pas
respecter effectivement la loi parce que
si on s'assie on s'attache à la loi et à
la justice dans ce cas là rien n'est
respecté nulle part Michel Guérin alors
moi j'étais pas à Cannes parce que mon
multiple me voilà il y avait pas de
raison que j'y aille mais est-ce qu'on a
moins parlé de cinéma que d'habitude
parce que est-ce que vous le regrettez
je n'étais pas à Cannes bon vous n'étiez
pas à Cannes
j'ai lu énormément tout ce qui a pu être
écrit sur Cannes et ça c'est quelque
chose que comment dire
ce n'est pas propre au cinéma c'est
propre à tous les arts il y a je suis
allée Biennale de Venise j'avais
beaucoup été au cinéma je crois essayer
de voir le maximum de choses c'est mon
métier et j'ai l'impression que depuis
deux trois ans il y a une forte
socialisation de la façon dont on parle
de des œuvres et que l'aspect
formel la narration psychologique qui
amène aux choses passe en second plan je
pourquoi pas moi je trouve c'est un
problème d'équilibre à trouver l'un doit
pas empêcher l'autre c'est ça surtout
que je veux dire on doit pouvoir la fois
parler en effet des résonances
contemporaines des etc on doit parler
aussi évidemment de la féminisation des
métiers de la culture tout ça est
important et je pense qu'il faut aussi
on doit pouvoir respecter la créatif
également et le venter sans qu'il y ait
une seule phrase sur un article qui
fasse référence à l'époque pourquoi pas
tout est possible la question c'est
trouver et série parfois et je le vois
presque encore plus dans les arts
plastiques au cinéma mais elles sont on
ne voit plus du tout qu'est-ce qui
l’artiste qu'est-ce qui fait que lui est
intéressant quelle est intéressante et
pas un autre et pas une autre voilà on
avait ici même à propos de Picasso
est-ce qu'on peut dissocier
l'artiste de son œuvre regardez ses
tableaux sans savoir quel était son
comportement je peux donc vis-à-vis de
de plusieurs historiens peuvent
documenter tout réécrire tout on peut
tout revoir des grands cinéastes ça
n'empêche pas qu'on peut voir les œuvres
je pense
la question du début est-ce qu'on peut
choisir un film sans se poser la
question des conditions dans lesquelles
le réalisateur ou la réalisatrice ça
peut arriver un film contemporain de
jouer choisir un film d'aujourd'hui en
disant c'est un bon film donc je le veux
dans mon festival même si je sais que le
réalisateur est un pardon
je pense que tout le monde se se pose
cette question mais on en revient
toujours à ça c'est il y a les questions
de la preuve quand même
alors vous allez dire oui mais c'est une
commodité que c'est d'éviter les
questions etc mais il faut pas non plus
évacuer cette question la question de la
preuve c'est ce qui nous fait vivre en
société et qui nous qui nous permet
aussi voilà je pense que c'est une
question de dosage de savoir ce qu'on
peut aller ou pas de voir qu'est-ce qui
reprochait à quelqu'un ce n'est pas
pareil quand vous avez je pense un
acteur qui a 10 12 14 plaintes contre
lui et puis vous avez un vous avez une
seule plainte je pense que tout ça c'est
des éléments qui c'est plein de
faisceaux qu'il faut croiser pour que
chaque patron de festival ou chaque
programmateur ou chaque journaliste se
décide quand il écrit alors vous parliez
je reprends la map c'est encore beaucoup
de thèmes à aborder on parlait notamment
des des conditions de travail pas
seulement des acteurs aussi de des
différentes techniciens sur un sur un
plateau je voudrais qu'on fasse un point
maintenant sur les questions salariales
et Quentin calmer va pouvoir nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Quentin on va parler des écarts de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes au cinéma il y a des exemples
marquants il y a tout à fait très
récemment une actrice a évoqué le sujet
frontalement il s'agit de Shar cette
zone la star américaine a jeté un pavé
dans la main on peut le dire c'était en
mars dernier elle a révélé les quarts de
salaire entre elles et Michael Douglas
en 1992 les deux acteurs partagent alors
la fiche du thriller Basic Instinct il
faut le dire à l'époque elle n'est pas
connue contrairement à son partenaire à
l'écran mais pour ce film Michael
Douglas a touché un cachet tenez-vous
bien de 14 millions de dollars elle de
son côté aperçu 500 000 dollars un écart
énorme alors qu'on a appris depuis que
le réalisateur un pôle Verhoven n'avait
pas respecté le consentement de Sharon
Stone nous concernant des scènes où son
intimité et dévoilée donc malgré ses
scènes très compliquées à tourner
l'actrice était Thomas 28 fois moins
bien payé que ça Costa masculine et 30
ans plus tard les femmes sont toujours
moins bien payées en moyenne que les
hommes voilà j'ai de la chance j'ai
trouvé un rapport du Centre national du
cinéma qui donne des statistiques très
précises candidate de mars dernier et
dans ce rapport que vous voyez à l'écran
et bien on peut lire que les comédiennes
sont moins bien payés en moyenne de 15%
par rapport aux hommes et ces écarts de
rémunération ne touchent pas que les
actrices en moyenne les réalisatrices
touchent 24 % de moins que les
réalisateurs alors qu'elles sont plus
nombreuses dans la profession elles sont
56% dans cette profession mais on voit
que sur les 21 métiers de production
cinématographique qui sont recensés dans
le rapport les femmes sont toutes moins
bien payées que les hommes à l'exception
de deux métiers les cascadeuses et les
musiciennes autre tendance de fonds les
difficultés pour les femmes à trouver
des rôles passer un certain âge
effectivement et d'ailleurs un
documentaire diffusé ce soir sur Canal+
revient sur ce phénomène avec ce chiffre
en 2021 les femmes de plus de 50 ans
représentent 22% de la population mais
seuls 7% des rôles il y a des femmes qui
réussissent à déjouer ce sort et qui
elle semble et bien pouvoir continuer
une carrière alors que d'autres et bien
ont des difficultés écoutez par exemple
le des Philippines Leroy-Beaulieu elle
raconte sa traversée du désert dans sa
carrière elle est maintenant redevenue
une star connue dans le monde entier
grâce à une série sur Netflix que vous
ne connaissez peut-être Émilie une
Perrus en tout cas elle elle a pu
témoigner au micro de France Inter il y
a quelques mois écoutez toute une série
d'actrices vous mais aussi Nicole Kidman
Gillian Anderson ont vécu une deuxième
carrière grâce aux céréales alors que le
cinéma aiment la chair fraîche
de d'une pièce d'Ariane mouchkine qui
disait aphrodite est le dieu du
siladaise du cinéma oui oui non c'est
vrai
c'est vrai les séries nous permettent à
nous les vieilles de revenir avec tes
rôles avec des choses qui sont
intéressantes à jouer parce que c'est
vrai que ça voilà la société elle est
quand même on le sait elle est multiple
des jeunes et des vues et il y a plein
d'histoires à raconter et voilà la vie
n'est pas terminée effectivement ni à 40
il y a 50 il y a 60 ans
sur l'âge des actrices c'est kygone
également un parcouru la Croisette cette
année Thomas je voulais finir vous
montrer une image de l'actrice Andy
McDowell connu pour son rôle dans 4
mariages à l'enterrement par exemple et
bien elle a arboré ses cheveux poivre et
sel sur le tapis rouge et elle
expliquait qu'une prise de conscience
était en cours dans le monde du cinéma
j'encourage les autres à le faire à se
sentir bien avec soi-même a-t-elle dit
en conférence de presse vendredi dernier
les femmes doivent se sentir bien avec
leur âge quel que soit leur âge a-t-elle
plaidé merci beaucoup Quentin Hélène
féginé est-ce qu'il faut
sur les femmes réalisatrices pour offrir
de beaux rôles aux actrices de plus de
50 ans mais en tout cas il faut
davantage effectivement de femmes
réalisatrices au moins pour multiplier
les regards et que la vision du monde
exprime au cinéma ne soit pas une vision
avant tout masculine
le regard masculin alors c'est
effectivement une théorie féministe qui
a été forgé par Laura melvet dans les
années
1970 dans un article qui s'appelle
plaisir visuel et cinéma narratif et qui
déconstruit finalement le mécanisme
patriarcal on va dire du cinéma à
travers la dénonciation pour simplifier
de d'un triple regard masculin qui
serait celui d'abord évidemment du
réalisateur et finalement ensuite porter
essentiellement sur des personnages
masculins dont on adopterait le point de
vue en tant que spectateur et du coup
nous publique nous serions finalement
dans
le regard donc masculin infinés bon
alors c'est une théorie qui a été
rediscutée par la suite d'ailleurs par
son autrice elle-même mais qui a
l'avantage de mettre en évidence
effectivement notamment au niveau de la
construction des rôles qu'il n'y a pas
de neutralité qu'il y a un point de vue
en fait qui s'élabore dans ces scénarios
après c'est pas parce qu'on est une
femme qu'on va nécessairement de manière
naturelle et essentielle lisse en
quelque sorte faire écrire de beaux
rôles pour les femmes en revanche c'est
quand même en général au moins une
expérience qui fait qu'on peut avoir un
autre regard qu'un regard hégémonique
masculin alors je voudrais que on ouvre
un autre chapitre dans ce débat
concernant les accusations visant Gérard
Depardieu dans une enquête publiée par
Mediapart 13 femmes accusent l'acteur de
violences sexuelles et sexistes léanique
Bridoux c'est vous qui avez mené cette
enquête pendant plusieurs mois qu'est-ce
que vous révélez est-ce qu'il y a une
forme de protection par le milieu est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça
alors pour être tout à fait précis c'est
ma collègue marine Turquie qui a enquêté
pendant des mois et des mois sur sur le
sujet secondé par Sarah Brett et en fait
c'est là où c'est très intéressant et un
cas assez emblématique de la discussion
que nous avons depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que nous révélons très témoignages
qui vise donc Gérard Depardieu qui nie
par ailleurs et c'est important de le
répéter tout faire répréhensible je le
dis d'emblée mais nous révélons c'est
très témoignage qui viennent s'ajouter à
une plainte qui avait déjà été déposée
par une une comédienne qui lui vaut une
mise en examen pour viol ça fait donc un
total de 14 témoignages jusque là on en
connaissait qu'une qu'un seul ces
témoignages y sont particulièrement
intéressants parce que ils viennent pour
pour beaucoup d'entre eux de comédiennes
mais de comédienne pas forcément
extrêmement connu de jeunes comédiennes
mais aussi beaucoup de techniciennes
assistante des petites mains du cinéma
pardonnez-moi l'expression qui sont très
souvent précaires qui risquent leur
travail qui craignent pendant toute
cette enquête de ne plus jamais
retravailler dans le milieu du cinéma et
qui le craignent toujours aujourd'hui et
donc on raconte voilà comment toutes ces
femmes témoignent de fait qui en fait
avait pour la plupart selon leur récit
et selon les témoins qu'on a pu
interroger lieu sous les yeux de tous et
de toutes et c'est l'autre point
extrêmement intéressant c'est que en
réalité le cas de Gérard Depardieu
montre bien les limites des espèces de
principes sur uniquement la justice ou
uniquement l'épreuve qu'il faudrait
apporter parce que on est face
évidemment un monument du cinéma
français personne ne le remettra en tant
de questions mais qui est par ailleurs
visible par une qui est mis en examen
donc c'est un fait judiciaire et qui par
ailleurs il y a des faits qui sont
presque sur la place publique depuis des
années sans que personne ne s'en soit
saisi sérieusement ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a des bandes dessinées des
interviews des instants filmés des
archives de Lina etc dans lequel on voit
des actrices raconter des conditions de
tournage où on voit même Gérard
Depardieu lui-même plaisanter
extrêmement grossier faire des allusions
sexuelles à une maquilleuse etc donc ça
montre bien que pendant des années on a
regardé cette réalité là je parle
vraiment de faits qui sont très
matérialisés cette réalité sans se poser
la question de ce que le signifiait sans
se poser la question du déséquilibre de
pouvoir de position qu'elle impliquait
entre évidemment un artiste un comédien
fabuleux et les personnes qui
travaillent avec lui au quotidien sur un
tournage en l'occurrence des jeunes
femmes souvent assez précarisées et et
cette espèce de ce que Marine Turquie a
appelé dans son papier la complaisance
française que ça interroge précisément
dans ce cas de figure qui qui est pour
moi justement à la croisée des chemins
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup de ce témoignage amoureux
là-dessus le temps a filé beaucoup trop
vite je voudrais qu'on parle aussi
financement du cinéma Michel Guérin
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
maintenant après une enquête comme celle
de Mediapart est-ce que vous imaginez un
producteur proposer un rôle à Gérard
Depardieu aucune idée ce que l'on
pourrait voir par rapport à l'agenda
qu'il avait qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce
qui continue qu'est-ce qui est arrêté je
crois qu'il y a un film qui est sorti ou
jouer un rôle de cuisinier pas longtemps
où j'ai l'impression qu'il y a eu quand
même beaucoup de comment dire ça de
précaution autour de la sortie comme si
la production était gênée près de sortir
le film avec même un panneau
d'avertissement etc etc je crois qu'il a
pas participé non plus à la promotion du
film ça donne je pense une idée de de
voilà maintenant ça fait 30 ans qu'on
dit que Depardieu c'est fini que chaque
fois il chute que que par ses ex on
disait par ses excès etc il a souvent
rebondi est-ce qu'il peut rebondir
encore une fois bon je pense ça va être
très difficile allez on prend quelques
minutes il nous reste un peu moins de 8
minutes pour ouvrir le dernier thème de
ce débat le financement du cinéma
français et donc c'est critique exprimé
par Justine trier qui venait de recevoir
sa Palme d'Or Émilie critique forte
contre le gouvernement oui alors juste
pour mémoire c'est la troisième femme
réalisatrice a remporté la Palme d'Or à
Cannes la seconde française pour son
quatrième film anatomie d'une chute qui
sera diffusée le 23 août alors après la
séquence émotion et les remerciements
d'usage elle s'en est en effet fortement
pris à la façon choquante dont la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites avait été je la cite nier et
réprimer alors c'est pas arrêté là elle
a poursuivi critiquant je la cite
toujours la marchandisation de la
culture que le gouvernement néolibéral
défend qui est en train de casser
l'exception culturelle française sans
laquelle je ne serai pas là c'est
exactement ce qu'elle a dit alors
évidemment elle a provoqué un terrible
la ministre de la Culture qui pour le
coup n'avait pas préparé sa réponse
contrairement Molière
elle s'est déclarée sur Twitter estomac
et par un discours si injuste le film
n'ayant pu voir le jour sans notre
modèle français donc juste Justine trier
avait dit que c'était quand même grâce à
l'exception culturelle française qu'elle
avait pu faire ce film d'autres
réactions oui certaines comme Valérie
Pécresse de la région Île-de-France ont
conseillé à la réalisatrice de ne pas
mordre la main qui la nourrit et pour
Eric woerts c'est l'anatomie d'un
naufrage pour Roland Lescure ministre de
l'Industrie c'est l'anatomie de
l'ingratitude d'une profession que nous
aidons tant alors on va regarder le
budget de son dernier 6,2 millions
d'euros pour le budget du film 900 000
euros viennent de France Télévisions 500
000 euros viennent d'avance sur Recettes
du Centre national du cinéma
1,2 millions de crédit d'impôts qui sont
octroyés sur avis favorable du CNC
également le Centre national du cinéma
et à des aides des régions de 170 000 de
la région Rhône-Alpes 150 000 de la
région nouvelle-aquitaine bref et puis
aussi des acteurs privés qui
interviennent par exemple 1,2 millions
de Canal+ le député Renaissance
Guillaume kasbariian qui est aussi
président de la commission des affaires
économiques à l'assemblée a d'ailleurs
proposé au passage d'arrêter de
distribuer autant d'aide à ceux qui
n'ont aucune conscience de ce qu'ils
coûtent au contribuable alors il faut
quand même savoir que le film ne coûte
quasiment rien au contribuable et
d'ailleurs c'est Pierre d'escure qu'il a
bien expliqué
le Festival de Cannes sur c'est à vous
il a bien expliqué que le système est
financé par des taxes sur l'industrie
cinématographique et non par de l'argent
public hormis crédit d'impôts ou les
aides des régions qui sont conditionnées
à des tournages qui seraient sur les
territoires concernés et ce même ancien
président du festival de Cannes a aussi
rappelé les autres figures du cinéma qui
avant Justine trier avait insisté sur la
nécessité de protéger et de préserver ce
système de financement du cinéma
français on parle quand même de Bert
c'était en 97 au César et de Ken Loach à
Cannes en 2016 alors d'autres réactions
cette charge contre le gouvernement
néolibéral ça a duré jouir les
oppositions bah forcément du côté de la
gauche notamment à l'image de Fabien
Roussel qui a dit marchandisation des
cornes marchandisations de la culture
bravo à Justine trier pour sa Palme d'Or
et son discours qui frappe si juste à
noter la réalisatrice elle est revenue
aussi sur ses propos pour bien expliquer
que c'était l'idée de la non rentabilité
des films qui devaient être préservés et
que Ken avait toujours été un endroit où
les gens s'exprimaient politiquement par
rapport à la situation du pays le retour
de la tradition de Cannes selon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon moi je dirais tout ça pour ça
enfin c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est
Claude Lelouch puisque c'était un de ses
films
de Justin Triet quand elle dit attention
on est en train de casser l'exception
culturelle sans laquelle je ne serai pas
là aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
est-ce qu'on peut aller jusque là
un système qui permet au cinéma français
d'être aussi fort quoi alors là ça
rentre ça exigerait de rentrer même dans
la réforme même qui est au cours au
niveau du CNC ça devient extrêmement
pointu là ça dépassera du coup mon
domaine pour aujourd'hui mais en tout
cas moi ce qui me frappe dans ces
déclarations c'est effectivement
la réintroduction de la politisation en
fait des discours à Cannes donc on
pourra se souvenir et vous le citez
d'ailleurs Michel Guérin dans le monde à
un moment fort en 1968 quand Godard dit
alors que finalement le festival va être
interrompu donc en mai 68 vous me parlez
la formule exacte c'est je vous parle de
solidarité avec les étudiants et vous me
parlez travelling et gros plan vous êtes
des cons et ben là d'une certaine
manière alors là moi j'en reviens à la
question aussi féministe mais c'est lié
en fait évidemment même à la question de
la politique et et plus largement des
retraites c'est que là au donc du
festival il y a effectivement tout un
discours qui a du mal à être entendu
alors même avec ce retentissement petit
ne pas être politique Michel Guérin
votre avis sur le financement il y a une
confusion incroyable parce que on peut
être un gras on peut être financé et
dire du mal moi c'est pas un problème ça
c'est important les retraites elles
disent qu'elle veut oui ça je suis
d'accord problème l'économie libérale
elle peut trouver ça pas bien elle a le
droit oui sauf qu'elle est financée
aussi par Canal+ et par Vincent
dire que le gouvernement actuel s'en
prend comme vous l'avez dit à
l'exception culturelle ça il faut le
prouver ça il faut donner des éléments
et franchement je pense que la source là
très précis factuellement il y a un
débat là-dessus etc mais je pense
qu'elle elle a passé d'éléments elle se
trompe je pense pas qu'elle c'est trop
tôt pour le savoir il y a en effet des
projets le patron du centre sur le
cinéma est remis en cause pour faire
quelque chose de beaucoup plus comment
dire industriel et qui ferait plus de
rentabilité des films mais actuellement
la majorité des films français ne sont
pas rentables ils continuent de vivre il
y a encore autant de films français qui
sortent donc je pense qu'elle a elle a
pas les éléments pour le dire pour
l'affirmer l'affirmer aux États généraux
du cinéma
qui est quand même tenu par des
producteurs productrices réalisateur
réalisatrices et des personnes de renom
techniciens techniciennes aussi
évidemment ces personnes n'ont pas
rencontrées n'ont pas réussi à
rencontrer la ministre de la Culture non
je crois pas rencontrer non plus le
Président du CNC qui refuse de les voir
donc en fait je pense qu'elle se fait
aussi le porte-voix de de ce mouvement
là qui qui a des choses à dire et à
défendre et c'est terminé merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt sur Public
Sénat vous pouvez évidemment retrouver
nos programmes en replay sur la
plateforme Public Sénat point fr Emilie
merci beaucoup la semaine prochaine ce
sera le retour de Laetitia crupost et un
bonheur de vous avoir sur ce plateau et
vous reviendrez en tant que cavité et
experte dans le sujet politique
évidemment je vous donne aussi notre
prochain rendez-vous politique l'invité
de la matinale c'est Olivier Marleix
vous le voyez en photo le président de
l'air a l'Assemblée belle soirée
[Musique]